hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
and welcome to another
winners on a wednesday episode where
every single week i
interview one of my success students
who've become financially free
by investing in property this week
you're going to be in for a treat i have
hannah mills
hannah i met her she was a solicitor
she's now full-time in property she's
financially free and she's doing some
crazy crazy deals
sometimes people also say to me they say
oh let's see where they are in two years
time
let's see where they are in three years
time so hannah's now been in the game a
very very long time so she's going to
give you an overview of exactly how
she's built up
her property portfolio hannah welcome to
winners on a wednesday
i'm awesome right now i'm normally this
is this is like a strange location for a
winner's wednesday because now we're in
your house and you can't afford carpets
so yeah what can i say we're
on budget on this one um no it's really
good having you down here actually i
know i'll see you travel all the way
down
and we're in the valleys and you're
actually in one of my refurb projects
with um
in our business with my business partner
and um yeah this is nearly done
so we're currently in the fourth bedroom
at the moment it's just been painted
literally
about four hours ago it's dry and um
yeah so uh thanks for coming down just
wanted to talk to you about everything
that's going on it's great and honestly
i mean this is your second time on the
on the show also you've been involved in
the eviction
yeah you were previous eviction you were
on it as a
as a delegate you put me for the middle
now you
really did why don't you start from the
beginning what was life like when we
very first met and how did you come
across
me my training property like what
happened yeah so i met you
in i think it's october 2018 on the
crash course uh
went down from london he was around
heathrow um never done any property
events
i was very i'm quite skeptical but i
really wanted to get into property and i
like watching youtube clips
and um my business partner got into your
um
same way youtube videos we were kind of
drawn to it he actually came away from
russia as well
so he you met your business partner gwen
yeah at the crash course
for the first time and he had flown in
from russia to be there you've driven
from wales to be there
you were skeptical what was the crash
course like
i'm gonna be honest the first five
minutes when you asked me to massage the
person that
left me i was a bit like right okay
what's this about but
it's very much about you kind of lose
your innovations and you're like right
we're all on the same page
everyone enjoy themselves and just buy
into it and once you buy into it
i i feel energized you can't not come
from that place not feeling energized
and going you know i'm literally gonna
i'm gonna
kick ass yeah um so i i really enjoyed
it and like i said off the back of it i
met quinn and at the time i didn't
realize that gwen was gonna be my
business partner um
but he is yeah um and i'll tell you a
little bit later about some of the cool
things that we're doing there and stuff
but
yeah that was pretty much where it kind
of really started um
fast forward a few months i handed in my
notice
i was working in solicitor and bristol
um and i just had enough i was like i
love property
i really want to get into it um and so
my entry into property was service
accommodation
yeah um fast forward a couple months
handed my notice in and i just went
right solid that's exactly what i'm
gonna do and i went into property full
time
i remember you quitting your job in fact
i don't know if you recall the
conversation we had just before you quit
your job oh maybe
do you remember it um a little bit yeah
i think you were basically like
from memory you were like saying to me
i'm thinking i quit my job
shut up i was kind of like you probably
should but obviously
you're a sister you've got a decent job
um and then next thing you just messaged
me like i've done it i've quit
yeah 100 so at the time i was kind of
lucky so i didn't just quit my job and
go
right that's it i'm just going to do it
i'd actually um started my own
rental service accommodation business i
only had a couple of units had three
units in cambridge i was managing
but from the income that they were
producing per month i could afford my
liabilities
so it wasn't the case i was i was going
right i'm just going to do it i had a
bit of a plan i'd already had a bit of
training and stuff and that's how i did
it
yeah tell me what for anyone watching
this that doesn't know what rent to rent
is
because rent to rent is something that a
lot of people are skeptical about yeah
maybe you were skeptically about it
at first and it's something that a lot
of my students
do successfully for anyone's watching it
doesn't quite know how it works
what is rent to rent so um really
simplistically
you take a landlord's property um and
you rent it from them
um and then you re-rent it out again so
some people call it subletting if you're
dealing with rent hmos it very much is
subletting
um but with rent to service
accommodation it's different because
you're not actually putting tenants in
there
you'll put guests but the idea of it is
very simple you rent a property
to then essentially rent it or book it
out
under your business right and and
there's so essentially there is no
tenant because
you're not a tenant of the property you
have a you have a corporate management
agreement with the with the landlord and
then you put a guest in there not a
tenant
so it's quite an interesting setup um
those first couple
of rental rents how much money did you
have to put into them and where did you
get that money from do you know what i
made big mistakes i made so many big
mistakes um
i probably put in let's say on average
um
about eight grand per property okay so i
was a good 24 grand in
um that is right isn't it yeah 24 grand
in
um i didn't really have the money where
did you get the money from borrowed
um i did um credit cards um
with zero percent balance because i had
a job as a solicitor i had a really good
credit rating right i could get really
low
um percentage loans yeah so i fiddled
that
um got them up and running learned a lot
of lessons managed them myself
saved a lot of money lost a lot of money
um learned the business and so it kind
of came to the point when
i was because i opened up four deal
sources
i um i i went outside myself and it got
to the point where i
i couldn't afford to take on these deals
but they're really good deals so i was
like what am i gonna do
so next progression was still sorting
right yeah
so that's and that's kind of like the
the formula that i do when i do a
financial freedom challenge
i take on some rent to rent yeah i
package and sell some properties to get
me some quick cash i put it into my rent
events that then gives me some
regular income and then develop onto all
the stuff which we get which we're going
to get to
um i just want to find out like you
joined the academy
which was how much did you invest in the
academy uh
i can't remember what fees are now i
think you invested about 12 grand
roughly around about that yeah and then
and then you invested
24 grand into rental months i mean yeah
it's a massive risk
right there yeah huge huge risk but you
know it was funny because um my partner
corey the other day said to me um
like where'd you see something property
and i
i knew i had to i had to know about it
had to be around people i had to
literally surround and live it breathe
it um because i
i was so passionate about it i i know
and fail and that sounds
like such a stupid thing to say but i
really believed it
um and so you some people may see it as
a risk for me
it was just a stepping stone a lot of
people would say that you'd be better
off
to spend 36 grand instead of throwing it
into rent to rent and throwing it on
training courses
to just buy a house yeah i mean what do
you think about that
uh for me i wanted a quick cash flow
yeah i wanted the
cash flow uh one so i could pay back the
loans um and two
because i thought to myself well wait a
minute if i can take a property
and i can earn let's say 1500 a month
for it
or i could buy one property and i could
earn 230 pounds off
after management fees and stuff like
that no brainer yeah absolute no-brainer
for three to five years if i can keep
that property
and i can make 1500 pound a month let's
say for three to five years
i've got a deposit there for a house
right right
and that's the way that almost do i want
to scale my business yeah for me i
thought the the best way to scale the
business would be to do
um rental rents look get loads of cash
flow investor profits get cash flow
invest the profits
yeah instead of having one property
waiting for a couple of years getting
capital appreciation remorsing and doing
it that way
yeah um at this point as well so you you
got your intervention
and and how are they did they go well
yeah great so i'm literally
where are my two and a half years in
yeah i handed one back
um but that wasn't because um i had to
um i actually changed my strategy i
handed a
one bedroom flat back and got a full
bedroom house right why it makes more
money
okay and you and i roughly pay out not
that much difference in rent
and liabilities so are you still making
money on those initial rental rents that
you got
how much are you making on the initial
three that you got now obviously one
you've you've upgraded but
of those yeah one of the upgrades i just
got almost the other day um but i'll
give you some i've got two bedroom
cottage
um and uh for one month i've got three
grand
program fee off the fees that came in
for three grand so through that three
grand in my pocket
so that's just one month like cash flow
yeah that's one month wow in the middle
of a pandemic in the middle of pandemic
so
that's in cambridge um for anybody
that's kind of you know like watch it
and you've obviously got different areas
that are different things
the thing with kanji at the moment is
it's actually one of the areas where um
astrazeneca is which created one of the
vaccines
so in terms of the pandemic and stuff
cambridge is mental so like i said
during a
though i got three grand bucket which is
which is crazy
because um some arrows are really
struggling um but that's just to do with
positioning of where you put your units
yeah
in your market knowing your market
exactly okay so you got your few rental
rents you gonna start
your deal sourcing business which is
packaging and selling deals and at this
point you just quit your job and i then
invited you to be on the eviction
so i quit my job to go on the eviction
oh no i didn't know that yeah so part of
the reason why because i couldn't get
the annual leave off
so i was like you know what because
alistair messaged me and said the
opportunity if you want to do this and i
was like
i feel like i have to do this i was like
well it's never going to give it
give me a time off and i was like i want
to work so i just i just want to spot it
so what if anyone doesn't know what is
the eviction so the eviction basically
was a tv show that you created
um and um it started with i think
there's 13 of us we lived in a castle
um and we had challenges pretty much
every other day
whoever failed on those challenges got
offended from a castle
um and that was basically it it was
it was very competitive yes very bit
do you know i didn't know what to expect
when i got there um because i didn't
actually know
a lot of people that were there um
didn't know james i didn't really know
anthony
um and auntie james off of that
experience are like two of my closest
friends
um in property and i go to them for
advice about everything
um and you've co-written a book with
them
with them which we'll talk about but
that was so so the eviction
um i mean you did very very well in the
eviction
i literally still speak to anthony about
it now you almost
won the eviction but you didn't quite
win the eviction but it doesn't matter
because you went on to storm anyway you
know i remember having the interview
with you afterwards and i was quite
upset because i
really i just wanted to succeed and i
remember saying to you obviously you you
gave anthony the the money and the gift
at the end of it i think it's twenty
thousand pounds and i remember having a
conversation with you and i said
it's okay don't worry i will make that
twenty thousand pounds back yeah i will
do it i'm determined that i'll do it
and i did do it yeah yeah exactly
and and you know what though you're a
very gracious almost winner
i was just like gracious loser but you
didn't lose you just didn't win
but but you know what though i mean
everyone on the eviction pretty much is
now financially independent
and doing extremely well we just did the
eviction
last year as well where you came back
but this time as a mentor
to offer support to the uh
um so okay so the eviction you did that
yeah how did the eviction change
so i know for you i mean you did the
academy which obviously the way you got
all the initial
knowledge and education but i know that
the eviction was like a real game
changer for you
massive and like i genuinely would say
life-changing because
um i was unsure about obviously quitting
my job but when i was there
um i learned so much from all the
different tasks because we did load
stuff we did deal selling we did that
refurb about hmo
um learning that and spending time with
people that have done things like i'll
constantly pick their brains so like
with anthony i'd be
like why have you done this and what
about this and james had asked about
deal selling and
um i'd ask everybody different things
even yourself
um outstanding spent a lot of time with
us because he was a mentor for our
particular team
um just asking those questions i came
away with so much knowledge
that um when i started sorting red
sourcing rental essays
um but after that we started sourcing by
refurbished refinances because i have
the knowledge
yeah um and then we start kicking off
our own portfolio yeah
which we're going to get to now because
the eviction now 2019
um you came on windows wednesday 2019 a
lot of people like to see the follow
through what happens
so since the eviction in 2019
what have you done probably safe to say
what haven't we done i think the only
thing we haven't done hmos um
to be honest with you so um
um for our own portfolio and also
sourcing them
um grew sorting business and started
buying properties
um and that was all sort of towards the
end of 2019
um started earning a nice amount of
money how much money do you reckon
since the last two years you're sourcing
company alone how much stretching is
done
um great question
um well we're doing on average probably
around
seven to ten deals a month at the moment
and how much on average is a deal worth
uh jeez that's crazy money yeah so what
you're doing like 25 grand a month
yeah so some we have peace and trust
because obviously deals to
complete over the line yeah you know
client account stays in client account
on average when you average it out
throughout the year we're doing anywhere
from 2019 um we were at the end of the
year doing anywhere between
sort of around about eight grand a month
and then it's massively scaled up
towards 2020
and part of that reason has been in the
scale of the source business has been
taken on employees
yeah because we've just managed to
source more properties
right and got more properties um and
we've also
managed to hit into foreign investors
yeah
so we've got a massive pocket of
different foreign investors everywhere
yeah won't just buy one deal they'll
take four or five at a time
yeah and when you say we you're talking
you and gwen yeah gwen i was noah gwyn's
also been on winners on a wednesday
yeah so is my business partner like i
mentioned earlier met him originally for
the first time in crash course spoken to
him a little bit before that but
actually physically met him and um
actually i bought him lunch on that
crash course he still owes me that um
and um so we only spoke sourcing
together we've grown it together i'm
based in south wales
he's best in essex and we have employees
split across two sites now
incredible yes also another thing as
well is you do a lot of joint ventures
with your investors
so with the street that we're in right
now it's kind of crazy because you're
like i own that house
how many houses just in this street do
you earn so far
four in the street and you own these
with joint venture partners because the
deals are so juicy
instead of just selling them yeah you
ask someone to put the money in yeah
and and this is crazy because you
started i know you were sliced and had a
very
very good job yeah but you actually
didn't have nothing
any money oh no i had nothing i was 20
how old was i then i was 25 i think
right just got my first big ticket job
um didn't have any savings
just bought a house i had nothing i
literally had nothing and now though
you know you own a lot of property
yourself you've got a deal sourcing
company making crazy money it's doing
really well
how much are your rental rents making at
the moment um so
i would say like my personal portfolio
i'm probably making
i would say on average about two grand
between two and three grand a month
profit sure but that's again like you
started with that
got to financial freedom and now you
that's just an extra income yeah
you know you diversify your portfolio in
terms of different income yeah that just
sticks over so
um that and my investment in that is
actually going into like
cryptocurrencies and stocks
right so you're diversifying like crazy
now yeah yeah
um because it's time to have really good
money um i don't just want to keep it in
the company so i'll either invest it
into one thing or invest it into another
yeah
why um out of all the investments
because i know you you're now a
businesswoman entrepreneur
you've got a business you've got a
property portfolio you're now putting
money into
crypto why is property the one that you
spend most time on and the one that kind
of
you know you know it's probably like um
symbolic being in this room
um because i love taking a property and
taking it from a really rubbish place
into a really good place and so this
this project particularly is about four
or five weeks away i think i was telling
you
there's nothing like taking something or
making something better adding value
even this property itself is just a you
know we turn it into a four bed from a
two bed
it's it it won't make huge amounts of
money but certainly satisfying about it
yeah
um and then obviously we've done this
now i'm trying to
make it even bigger with developments so
not just one property but multiples
um just love it i just love taking
something and turning it into something
else
so you've joined ventured with james
armstrong yeah on the house just across
the road you can't see it give me give
me an an example a case to be on the
sort of on the figures of these types of
properties so the one
that we're in right now for example yeah
so um they all say with deal sources
they keep the best deals
is kind of true you do and this was very
much one of them so this property we
bought
and the next one we're buying as well
never went on the market so we managed
to get it below market value so this one
was bought 69.
yeah uh market value will probably be
between 85 and 87
right now the market value very good
deal yeah really good deal um and so
um we're going to spend roughly i think
between 30 to 32 on the refurb
so all in you're talking about 102. yeah
depending um charged me for this house
yeah
build up um it's gonna re-value out i
would say i'd be comfortable with
revaluing out between 140
to 142 but on the open market it will
sell for more
um it will sell probably definitely 145
to 150 maybe even a little bit more
so you're talking a clean sort of like
45 grand profit
which is crazy are you going to
refinance or sell it
this one's going to be flip just because
we want to get a cash injection so we
can start
basically um just um
put it into other projects yeah the one
next door is going to be um refinance
we will pull all the money out of that
one um and that will rent roughly for
around six seven five per calendar month
so i mean i would say
about four seven five profit when did
you first go from deal sourcing and
passing other people deals for a fee to
saying actually you know what i'm going
to keep what would you what was your
first
and when i first started doing viral
films through violence didn't all
know an awful lot about it so i came
straight up the eviction was full of
ideas
and you just want to go yeah great want
to get stuck into it i didn't quite know
how to source them so i co-sourced
loads of them yeah some really good
deals like pull your money out deals
and a lot of the sources are like i
can't believe you're not keeping this
and it
switched something in my head and i was
like well why aren't i keeping it yeah
and so it came to a point with a deal in
mountain ash where i saw it i was like
these are really good figures and i said
to gwen i was like
we should we should start being a
portfolio and he's like 100 degree
and then i just went and asked someone
for the money and they gave it to me
where was this property
mountain ash literally about probably
about 15 minutes over that side of the
valley so another valley's house
um turn that into a three bed from a two
bed yeah um
and it's a case of literally going all
right well why aren't we doing this and
i was like
there's no reason the only reason is
money um so what do we do about it ask
people for money and that's just
actually saying that one of the people
that gave some money for it um
was i met on the um incredible
which is another training program of
part of the academy so um
and that particular investor just keeps
giving us money yeah yeah
that's the thing as well with with
education like the academy and the
training that
you you purchase through our company
it's not just the training it's also the
networking
i can't even tell you how for me um like
i learned a lot from other people and
and and that type of thing um i learned
so
much from networking just listening to
people speaking to somebody you
everyone's interlinked you just don't
quite realize how and everyone's got
something that they can offer you
yeah um and yeah and so that's basically
how we started the portfolio and the
buyer referred which we find outside of
the sorting business
what's your strongest reason for doing
all this
100 um freedom in terms of time
and how i want to live my life so you
probably know this better than anyone if
you want to spend time with your kids
your family you can do it because you
don't have to worry about going to work
and bringing money in and things like
that and for me i got to a point where i
was like
i still want to be stuck in the rat race
i just didn't want to be
um getting up at five in the morning and
coming home at eight at night
and hating my job i i couldn't do it um
and so it got to a point where i was
like
i've got no choice this has to work i
have to make it work
and i loved it so i was quite passionate
about it um the time and
time and freedom to do what i want so
for instance um
my partner now works full-time in the
business that's amazing
so we've managed to open up a full-time
wage
for her and five other people yeah um
which is cool
so you've got six full-time members of
staff now yeah so five that we have on
the payroll and one that just sort of
dips in and out because he's doing his
own
his own type of thing but he tends to
find like developments and things for us
which is awesome um
just the freedom to do what i want if i
want to go into your house if i want to
go on holiday if i want to be able to
afford
x amount of things then i don't have to
worry about saving for four months
um well if you want to take an afternoon
off and show me around your portfolio
yeah exactly but i'm so so pleased what
you've done and it's really interesting
as well because
when people start out in prophecy a lot
of the time they say to me you know i
want to do development i want to do this
and i'll say
no become financially free james the
same yeah i'll say become financially
free
get some rents around build your
experience because you're going to mess
up on your first deal you said it
yourself even though you went through
the training
your rents have been she said you made
some mistakes you put a bit too much it
still paid off
yeah but you messed up you're better off
to mess up on a small deal than a big
deal
one of the things that really excites me
is to see that now you're scaling up
yeah and i mean tell me about some of
the stuff that you're doing right now
so um we've got um one
two three four uh reefer projects that
um are about to be underway for our own
portfolio
yeah and we've got a load of investors
properties
um i'm running out builders at the
moment um so that's really cool
and we've got a couple of rent to rent
um in
i'll tell you this one this is a really
cool one in newport uh we had a
seven-day hmo we turned into an apart
hotel um
and we rented that out to the council
during lockdown
um they were paying us about seven grand
a month literally we're making
profit we're making around about three
and a half grand profit
come again tell me through that deal so
this is this is a hotel
yeah um that we turned into like sort of
like a mini of hot hotels got two
kitchens two bathrooms and then
seven double bedrooms all one suites um
and obviously locked down here we were
running it as a part hotel literally
just launched it rent around
yeah and they closed down all of the
hotels so you can do it so we were like
what we're gonna do
so we were working with a management
company um really good management
company
um and they said well look we've got you
know an idea this has come up what do
you think and i was like
yeah go for it so what it was was um the
council got given money to basically
get people off the streets because
coronavirus and that type of thing um
they approached us we rent a property
great okay
um you know how much is it we just put
went
i don't know
um and basically that was it they paid
just over seven grand a month
and how much were you paying the owner
so all in all because we've got
furniture
and things like that we're probably in
for about 300 including bills and
everything
so you're paying three thousand and
you're and you're getting the guaranteed
rent from the council for seven grand
oh my goodness so we paid management out
on top of that um but all in all we're
making a round about
someone's slightly different battery
half grand profit that's crazy because
for a lot of people that is
that's financial freedom in one rental
rent deal it's mental isn't it yeah
so that was one uh we also had a full
bed house in in cardiff that did really
well before kind of lockdown
kind of hit we had construction workers
in there again we were making
around 1500 pounds or two grand a month
um profit
it was it's crazy we're bringing in five
grand for that
um and the bills on that are around two
thousand two hundred two hundred
yeah so the rent's right side of things
we really kind of perfected based on
because we had a portfolio as well he
knows about rental rent
we perfected it um picked good areas
picked good clientele so that was doing
well um but now
we're going bigger and going into
developments
you joining the club i'm trying i'm just
copying you basically
but you know what though anthony james
a lot of people from the eviction are
now in development
which is bigger and better so talk to me
about sort of so
um horrible building and we currently
going from planning over to
21 or 23 flats there um so we're looking
at
um a nice profit on that one what sort
of profit are you thinking so
um i think we're looking at anywhere
between 1.2 to 1.6
incredible yeah so now it's like
literally gone from no money
to financial freedom sir do you know
what it is i think you probably
um feel the same about this you also you
started doing um
uh developments and things like that um
off the back of your experience of doing
like biorefurbish requirements hmos
once you find your first development
they just kind of keep coming don't they
yeah and you're like oh my god and you
just start noticing them
yeah and i think that's what is gonna
happen this year if we're gonna do a lot
more but you've built yourself
up to that yeah in the same way that i
am i mean i've been improv i was in
probably
many years before i started doing like
lands and
and and developments i mean but but
you've gone on the same journey
but like a condensed version of what i
did
much much quicker you know much quicker
than what i did
and um you know it's just incredible so
i'm i'm super pumped what would you say
to somebody that was
you know your words of advice to someone
that was wanting to i mean i know you've
worked
incredibly hard to get to where you've
got to and
where you've got to in just what like
three years yeah is is
is rare yeah right it's not normal
you're like a perfect case study to an
academy member
you know i mean a lot of people might
become financially free yeah
the level you've got is rare but someone
starting out
best piece of advice from getting
started what would you say um
i would probably say that if you're
already thinking about getting started
then you've got to be passionate so you
don't need to worry about that
um biggest thing for me probably was the
people yeah that i was with
um money comes and goes you can always
get money you'll always be able to find
money somewhere
if the deal is good enough you'll always
find money but people you can't
and i think the biggest thing for me is
i've had people around me that have just
been supportive
so like for instance like my partner
when i said i'm quitting my job and
going on the eviction
most people would be like i was earning
47 grand a month like for
20.
yeah um and she was just like yeah go
for it what's gonna make you happy
yeah and if i have bad days and stuff
it's always there um with the support
but the other key thing for me was i
learned so much from other people that
are just doing it
that didn't want anything from me in
return they didn't have money
they didn't want um uh anything like
that it was just you helped me i helped
you
yeah and so i've learned a lot from like
you said the people that i've met um
on on your courses um and they become
friends
um and we share that knowledge so people
100
yeah getting around the right people 100
because the worst people bring you down
you've seen it right people probably go
on the crash course and they're there
with their partner or their friend
and they're they're into it and then
their partner friend is like that's
never gonna work well that's not true
you can't produce that per month and if
you're around people like that then
you'll you'll
start to become a habit yeah it's so
true environment is so
it's so powerful so yeah i say people
yeah
and i think for me as well it's great to
see um i mean i make a lot of friends
i know i run the academy yeah and i
started the academy but it's kind of for
me it's more like a community rather
than
it's it's not about me it's about
ricky anthony alistair and yourself and
all you know
it's a community um and for me it's so
powerful almost becoming seeing us
so like having someone who's a student
who comes to me to look for
oh how does this work but then ends up
kind of like becoming a peer
yeah and i i start joint venturing with
them or like how we
we co-wrote a book together i know yeah
what was the book called
uh compliance made easy
how can you forget the name of your own
book
i've even got it like in my office and
it's there um and i sent a copy to my
mum my dad
and my nan and i even wrote in it and i
was like it's my first book
yeah and you know what though um the
book we a few of us co-wrote that from
the academy yeah and
and i mean what was it about for anyone
that's interested basically
um it's not the most exciting subject
but it's probably one of the most
important
and it's about um compliance in all the
different sort of major strategies that
you could use
hmos rental rents and that type of thing
um myself anthony james and you found
quite useful because a lot of people
when they get started in property they
don't know what they're doing whether
what business to form
what account to open um kind of like an
entry-level book
so to make make sure people are doing it
right there's also a lot of people that
i mean
in my in my opinion that over complicate
the compliance
make it sound scary and hard probably to
make themselves look intelligent or
because secretly they don't want you to
do it so for me my
involvement for wanting to co-write the
book with you guys was
really just to demystify illegal i mean
your background is solicitor so you've
got a law background
i've been in the property business for
12 years so i understand how the
property
laws work but i think it really helps a
lot of people just demystified it so if
anyone's watching
to search for it on on amazon yes
compliance compliance made easy
um so so that was a rockstar what would
be your the highlight of the last three
years what would you say
oh god um
[Music]
right i can't just pin it down to one
through one thing um
quit my job going full time yeah uh 100
percent the eviction
the first five february finance that we
bought because that's a milestone
um and then securing the lease option in
cardiff that's that's
probably yeah that those are the main
things um
and no i had a fifth one um getting
employees
so i've always worked under people
before and so when when
girls like i think we need to expand and
i was like go on look i'll go with you
on this
um when we've got employees it's
suddenly quite weird that they come to
you
like i'm 28 years old i've only ever
been an employer i've never been
anybody's boss
um but that's a real highlight for me
because we we employ mums
on purpose so the reason why we do it is
because we found that there's a lot of
moms out there that had kids
but the moms that we employed who worked
in like magic circle firms
and the reason why they stopped working
is because they're kids and so what they
do is they work remotely with us but
they've got that knowledge and that um
that understanding of big companies and
they've really driven the
business forward so i probably said
that's that's my fifth one it's getting
employees
a lot of highlights there man yeah it's
been it's been epic
the next four years are gonna be mental
if that's the highlight so far yeah a
lot of highlights
well listen man absolute pleasure to sit
with you in your house and see what
you're doing
i'm sure and also thanks for coming on
because it's so easy to get so busy
yeah in actually doing property and
stuff that it's like but but the fact
that you've you know
put the time out yeah and spend an
afternoon sharing inspiring other people
showing them what you've done
i think it's really really uh really
generous on your on your on your part i
know you're busy late now high demands
um but yeah honestly really proud of
what you've done thank you
and it's just such an honor to be a part
of your you know part of your journey
no fine and like i said um let's see
where we are in a couple years time
yeah maybe you'll be sitting in like a
mansion well maybe you'll own the whole
street
this street exactly so um yeah well that
is the plan just just don't tell the
neighbors
but i think as well like you know i'll
just end on this
if someone said to me pick the top 10
people that you would trust to do a deal
with
like a joint venture with or whatever
you'd be one of the ten so you know if
anyone's watching this that
has the opportunity to meet with you or
to do business with you i just say
do it because you really know your stuff
and really work hard have a lot of
integrity
so you know massive shout out to as a
person as well as what you've achieved
thank you
thank you all right so welcome hey guys
that was hannah i mean
honestly this is why i do what i do just
to see people's journey
not just three months later or six
months later but three years later
complete change life you know it's for
me it's really really rewarding so if
you want to part of the journey
i'd say all starts where does it start
crash course
it all starts at the crash course so i'm
gonna leave a link in the description
where you can get a free ticket
on the house to come to the property
investors crash course which is where
condensed everything that i know about
properties condensed into one day
where you can learn exactly what hana
learned hope to see you succeed
subscribe
smash the like button also every single
week i do one of these interviews with
somebody new
so you can see a whole playlist right
here you can subscribe right here and i
look forward to seeing you next time
[Music]
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you